foreign
[Music]
how long will you be staying I don't
know where are you staying no idea any
drugs or alcohol no
[Music]
unanimous
wanted to spend a little time with my
grandson that's what it's all about
you're not supposed to smoke here what
Peter mom does Dave know you have his
Klingon sword it's a glaive and no he
doesn't
you run around like a kid and you're not
a kid anymore you're a man ow you know I
think I turned out okay right oh you
live with your mom and she lives with me
okay
but I pay the mortgage
you run away from people who love you
as important is family do you know what
it's like how people constantly ask you
about your brother
it was bad
you don't exactly lead a quiet life
now I try to do nice things yeah they
still think I'm like a joke
[Music]
it's more like a regular type bike we're
in comedy you gotta be able to walk away
from anything in your life in 30 seconds
flat that's why I got nothing tying me
down
if you're a kid oh yeah
[Music]